c'est le procès qui a tenu en haleine
toute l'amérique au printemps dernier la
fin du feuilleton dans le procès johnny
depp l'actrice a été reconnu coupable un
procès en diffamation qui aura duré plus
de six semaines et qui aura finalement
donné raison à johnny depp face à son ex
compagne amber heard
est ce que la pensée que monsieur depp a
des preuves fiables prouvant que
mademoiselle hurd a agi avec malice la
réponse du jury et a misé sur importante
procès l'acteur avait réussi à gagner
l'opinion publique il semblerait que
depuis les choses est un peu changé
aux états unis de nombreuses militantes
féministes ont dénoncé le traitement
médiatique et la haine diffusés à
l'encontre dans le rock durant ce procès
quoi
de neuf
là c'est l'ami tu veux des avocates
andrea burkhardt 6000 pages de documents
inédits ont été révélés apportant les
preuves de violences sexuelles et
physiques de la part de johnny depp
parmi ces documents des témoignages de
médecins des maîtres cacher mais aussi
des photos et des audio qui auraient été
falsifiés par l'acteur
sur les réseaux sociaux le hashtag amber
heard 10s de naples au jaï comprenez
amber mérite des excuses a fait son
apparition en soutien à la star moi
aussi amber heard mérite des excuses
pour ce qu'elle a subies de la part de
cet homme et de ses fan dérangé comme
des milliers d'internautes des
célébrités comme bella hadid et lille
ira tacos qui ont pris la défense de la
crise
[Musique]
on
bird a fait appel de sa condamnation en
juin dernier ces révélations pourraient
venir tout remettre en question et cette
fois-ci l'opinion pourrait bel et bien
changé de côté
alors ce qui est intéressant pour les
spectateurs qui ne regarde si vous
n'avez pas tout suivi c'est qu'en fait
c'est une avocate en fait qui s'appelle
andrea burkhardt mondiale influence us
parce qu'en fait elle regardait tout le
temps et elle est l homme l vulgariser
un petit peu le procès sur les réseaux
sociaux pour expliquer aux gens ce qui
se passait tout le temps ce qui est
avocate et en fait elle a décidé de
faire en fait de racheter des dossiers
qui n'avait pas été traité pour un
procès parce qu'elles seront ce qu'elles
appellent des vices de forme nocturne
sur des pièces qu'on ne peut pas
utiliser au procès elle a donné beaucoup
d'argent en fait elle a touché de
l'argent via des fonds parce que la fan
appel de fonds il a repris toutes ces
pièces qui n'avaient pas été sortis
pendant le procès et elle s'est rendu
compte qu'avec toutes ces pièces si en
fait peut-être y avait pas eu toutes ces
magouilles de vice de forme johnny depp
aurait peut-être perdu parce qu'ils
avaient des pièces qui sembleraient
prouvé qu'en réalité il a vraiment été
violent et qui voudra frapper ça tombera
alors tu crois là j'ai de l'estimé à
merci beaucoup oui mais des
conversations qui ont été retrouvés des
esgaulx la question pour que vous et des
petits noms et oui c'est quoi non à
laval jacques les soirs vous choquer que
les stars échangé à
la rue dit non pour vous dit non il veut
vraiment c'est pourquoi non à leur
ferions déjà il faut rappeler que leur
leur brouille lors c'est plus qu'une
brouille ses travers d'entre eux c'est
comme un match de tennis et à dire
classe il y aura une troisième manche
pour rappeler qu'il avait perdu la
première parce qu'ils avaient attaqué
ces propos dans un journal anglais et il
a gagné la deuxième suite à des propos
d'un journal américain c'est le
washington post c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
que ça a été diffusée et que ça autant
fait réagir donc la troisième manche on
verra où elle se situera et comment elle
se situera et en fonction des éléments
qui aura mais de toute façon ça va
continuer une fois deux fois jusqu'à qui
en a un qui soit vraiment ko mais pour
l'instant réelle et pérenne car au ps
qui sont sortis pensions sont pas
extrêmement à charge contre lui on aura
des nouvelles comme il y en avait il
alors des mots a fait mais c'est le sms
entre johnny depp et l'acteur paul
bettany ils se sont envoyé un message en
disant les deux hommes ont su que
suggérez qu'amber heures parce que test
de flottaison c'est un test qu'on
compose est passé aux sorcières à
l'époque on les attache les mains et
pieds liés on les mettait dans l'eau
pour voir si elle flottait ou pas
l'hôtesse et
82 cents en progrès nous étions
lanouaille du
jeu noyon l'avant l'abs et je mènerai
son corps brûlés après pour m'assurer
qu'elle est morte enfin pas mais si
jamais ça qu'introduit mec de mode de
mecs bourrés salah stills and nash a
misé beaucoup de temps et sous 2 buts
est ce que tu en vois toi / funk obama
mais lui n'a jamais mis sur un axe et de
meilleures copines thon rouge pourrait
le but était redouté s'est jamais envoyé
maison avait brûlé le juste après ce que
tu connaissais pas fait de cette
exposition oui benoît par là je n'ai pas
d'infos à bercy
n'a pas à se positionner pour ou contre
l'impression que chaque mois et un
rebondissement on est plutôt du côté
d'un beurre parce que là bon et on est
plutôt du côté de non franchement je
pense qu'il faut je me suis perdu mais
ce qui est important c'est que les
laissa les laisse vivre leurs trucs et
des toits sont la justice a eu raison
humilié innocent elle va payer très cher
sur la tête contre mais c'est que pour
les caméras tu parles vraiment comme ça
dans la vie
[Applaudissements]
c'est un vrai bois essaye avec une
baguette de pain il n'y a pas de caméra
mathieu mais c'est très normal j'aurais
dit comment je vais bonjour je voudrais
2 euros non de bagatelle
oui j'oriente sur ce qu'a dit déborah
parce que c'est avec cette histoire de
première deuxième troisième manche est à
dire qu il est extra y en avait déjà eu
dans le dernier procès où il disait des
trucs abominable sur l es ça n'a pas
empêché de gagner isa et puisque ces
loups du fonds elle avait été remise à
d'accord mais ça aurait été divulgué
donc je dois pas d'autre en fait c'est
ça que je déçois d'autres voilà et donc
les épaules c'est normal qu'ils le
lâchent parce que finalement au bout
d'un moment ils n'en peuvent plus ils ça
ils savent qu'ils sont dans un truc sans
fin où il y aura des choses graves qui
se succéderont donc ils peuvent pas le
soda il ya ya ya ya aussi des documents
des sorties comme quoi va là il prend
des pilules pour pour l'érection parce
qu'il en a plus bombe à wil et mouret
l'histoire quoi qu'il en soit elle est
assez sordide c'est à dire que elle elle
a eu un beurre d'un traitement
médiatique qui a été effectivement assez
inégal par rapport à johnny depp qui a
été extrêmement soutenue par ces femmes
parce qu'elle a moins de fans parce
qu'elle est moins connue parce qu'elle
est moins aimé qu il ne reste pas moins
que c'est quand même une femme je pense
qu'ils aient un petit peu tordu je pense
qu est un petit peu paumé n'en reste pas
moins qu'ils sont deux à avoir été dans
une relation toxique une relation
violente à laquelle il a participé et
donc le doute subsiste et quand on est
une star et qu'on est mêlé à ça il ya un
moment donné on n'a peut-être pas envie
de prendre le parti d'autant plus qu'il
va y avoir un matin là il ya le procès
qui va sortir aussi en en doc sur
discovery plus là absolument 19
septembre avec d'autres éléments du
procès donc effectivement après le texto
non tu parles c'est vrai que
personnellement on a déjà pu écrire
j'aimerais qu'ils crèvent ce qu'ont bien
sûr milliard amis bien sûr voilà le
potache à la wii a damé mans et on voit
autre chose c'est terrible cette notion
de c'est l'opinion qui fait alors voilà
on dit ça et là ça va d'un côté de
l'autre mais maintenant si on me disait
tout simplement que ces 2,5 mais qui se
sont tirés la part l'autre parce qu'ils
étaient toxiques tu es ben oui sont tous
les deux toxiques ils sont tous les deux
singles et ils sont tous les deux coquet
et puis maintenant il faut que tous les
deux sont à creuser